you can't just think that it was the it
was these pharmaceutical companies it
was the people in power and those people
empowering governmental power but there
also our celebrity class because there
were
an endless amount of celebrities saying
complete nonsense and for some reason we
live in a culture where people care what
celebrities say right these are actors
for the most part and actors act they
don't actually do anything they act
they're not actually doing the things
that they're pretending to do they're
pretending that's how it works and we
this video was going around over the
weekend and I thought it was worth
seeing again this is Tom Hanks beloved
Forrest Gump Tom Hanks Wilson on the
island he went to the moon what else did
he do he burbs that movie The Burbs give
me one more give me one more which one
Polar Express he's been around the block
this Tom Hanks guy done a lot of stuff
right but listen to him in 2021 talking
about vaccines
I don't get it
I simply do not get it it is literally
the least you can do and if you want to
if anybody wants to build up an argument
about doing the least they can do I
wouldn't trust them with a driver's
license I mean when you drive a car you
got to obey speed the speed limit you
got to use your turn signal you got to
avoid hitting pedestrians if you can't
do those three things then I get it you
shouldn't be driving a car if you can't
wear a mask and wash your hands in
Social distance I I don't understand I I
got no respect for you man
maybe you should stop going to Tom Hanks
movies like I don't really mean to make
this about Tom Hanks is he is he the
worst person in the world but that
notion right like if you don't wear a
mask and you don't uh wash your hands
and socially distance things that all
turn out to be nothing yes washing your
hands is fine okay but social distancing
was nonsense wearing a mask was complete
nonsense and when you even literally if
you go right now go to your CVS or your
Walgreens or whatever drugstore you go
to go to the mask section and look at
the boxes and the boxes all say these
masks don't stop covid right so he had
no idea what he was talking about but he
was saying if the people who don't
follow the system and what he's saying
there is the system's been really good
to me right the guy's worth hundreds of
millions of dollars he's a massive Elite
Superstar and again I'm not saying that
he himself is the worst guy in the world
because he probably isn't that would be
he probably isn't but all of these
people
carried water for a system that was
crashing down on the rest of us and that
is not good and we cannot forget it
[Music]